I always say this for many many years
their fans cannot fight for you and one
thing I know I can do I can fight
I'm a chess player I play chess every
move is calculated I give my credit
about what I do in the ring but I don't
get my credit about what I do on the
outside
hello believe nation its Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves and
my sincere hope is that if you see in
yourself what I see in you you'll be
able to change the planet so to help you
on your journey today we're going to
learn from one of the greatest boxers of
all time floyd mayweather and my take on
his top ten rules of success vol 2 rule
number seven is my personal favorite and
i'd love to know which one that you guys
like the best also as you're watching if
you hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down in the
comments below and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired by it as
well and if you leave it within the
first couple hours of this video going
live you have a chance to win one of two
daily prizes
you'd have a certain charisma about
yourself a certain look about yourself
that pay-per-view a pay-per-view
attraction that pay-per-view look I know
because I was a young kid and I had that
same look certain fighters Oscar de LOI
he had to look Sugar Ray Leonard I had
to look Mike Tyson had to look certain
fighters have that look in their
charisma about them to become
pay-per-view stars and if anybody know
about who can become a pay-per-view star
you talking to the king of pay-per-view
you know you have to realize we broke we
did we did so many record-breaking
numbers we don't no longer call the
pay-per-view we call it may preview it
reminds me of Ali and Frazier the not to
fight but for the bill for a game the
build-up is the pregame and I'm watching
you I know you you my friend I'm
watching you hold your composure
it's a few times you wanted to suck them
and I know you and I know he was being
very professional boss I must conduct
myself in a boss manner in front of my
employee cuz maybe who is my employee is
that the attitude that you had I mean I
just feel like you know taking a chance
of you know when he touched me a couple
of times and he says some hello very
disrespectful marks a few times he said
a few things it pushed my buttons but
just what experience
I'm not fin to is it it'll cost us in
the long run it'll cost us hundreds of
millions that we all could be putting in
our account right if we do it the smart
way so I'll say you know what i'ma hold
out I'll wait to August 26 and do it
when it counts not nothing I'm not gonna
do it what don't count
I never focus on anything but the guy
that's in front of me because when it
comes down to it I always say this for
many many years their fans cannot fight
for you and one thing I know I can do I
can fight so the fans when I shout
scream up I don't worry about nothing I
just you know keep my composure I stick
to the game plan
constantly keep coming ahead coming here
pushing me push
pushing him back pushing him back you
know when he first come out for the
first 20 seconds that a hurt around when
he go when he go down when he go back to
his corner and he sit down I said when
he come on he's gonna come out for 30
seconds and fight hard and then he gonna
break and once you break that's when
i'ma shoot a hard shot to the body
hitting with a hard shot up top and keep
pushing and back keep pushing him back
remember I told you guys wait wait
doesn't win fights fighting wins fights
and then you know when I said talking
doesn't win fights fighting wins fights
meaning that when we was on the you know
we went on stage for the weigh-in I
don't have to do no more talking we
fighting tomorrow so I did I did enough
talking on our tour basically so you
know everybody said I'm able he was
talking on the tour okay I did I didn't
I did a lot of talking on tour but now
it's time to fight we 24 hours we're 24
hours away from what the biggest fight
in the world the biggest combat fight in
the world
there's no need to talk anymore there's
no need to talk anymore
it's the kid kid and Taylor
he has um cancer kids said my only wish
before I die is to meet Floyd Mayweather
and that's not the only kid that I've
been through that you know that that has
said that is it that is his wish his of
his or her wish but this little kid
named Taylor and he came to the boxing
gym and waited for me I got here on time
and when I seen him it brought tears to
my eyes
because he kind of reminded me of my
oldest son when he my oldest son was
young and his kid is only ten years old
so we took a picture after he was here
he sent me box he seen me train we
talked he asked me so many questions but
[Music]
we took a picture I wanted to post it on
social media and I couldn't post it
because I couldn't find the words to say
every day I think about this this child
every day so yesterday when I woke up
before I came to the box gym I said you
know what I want to do today I'm gonna
call a tailor I want to spend time with
this kid so I caught I got in touch with
his dad I said I want to go to gamestop
what the GameStop took the kid and
that's it get it get everything you want
to get just kidding I mean life is
priceless and went out and life is
priceless
and your health is your wealth so a lot
of times they say Floyd once your stick
around boxing you can make this and you
can make that you can make this to your
two years off I'm gonna make a ton of
money but remember your health is your
work and to the fans that are still
upset with what went on in the Pacquiao
fight you say what the fans had to be
mad at Pacquiao they can be mad at me I
done my job I never said I was a
checkers player I'm a chess player I
played chess every move was calculated
but the finishes thought about that when
I was when I was running through
everybody at one particular time so now
I'm just older and wiser I'm older and
wiser it's like fine woman I get better
with telling everybody know in this room
that's watch me fight I could've easily
outbox Conor McGregor Conor punished
them or night that's not what I wanted
to do I wanted to go out with a bang I
told you guys I would come straight
ahead I feel like I owe that to the fans
for the Pacquiao fight even though I
don't owe anybody nothing I put the
pressure on myself and did it myself and
that was a goal of mine I told you guys
that this fight wouldn't go to distance
it's over 300 not 200
yes records show that you broke your I
want to say this with Showtime and CBS
with the deal they gave me just the
three pipes with the Canelo the Pacquiao
and this fight
what kind of McGregor I think 750 I made
over Bayon dollars in my career but just
as all three fight 750 from CBS so a
show too so what your name is money and
obviously they let me retire and be
happy please I've tried three times see
this please okay please okay you're done
you're done I'm not gonna bother it
again
tell him he's done he's done lady they
done don't box let's go please not
fighting again you don't want nobody for
an MMA or boxing calling me out no more
telling don't call them out anymore he's
retired ah he's gonna be happy a man
that has never been in a boxing ring is
in the ring with the best ever that's
what you talk that's what you describe
yourself as being I don't ascribe myself
we must realize men like women line
numbers don't lie 49 and out not just 49
I mean whether that's didn't didn't
broke every record in boxing when we get
to talk about highest gate even it was
like right now they said off mayweather
fight didn't sell out well you know
woman when they do sell out I think I
read somewhere like you know the live
gated reached like 80 some million for
this fight already we already had 67
million for those others saying that
Mayweather is not doing numbers anymore
[Music]
far as taking the less punishment I took
less punishment than any fighter not
just best defense let's talk about
offense the most accurate fighter of all
time on the outside the ring it's not
just about being in the inside the ring
I already already conquered that I was
I'm even smarter on the outside you know
I have to be a genius to even make this
to even make a fight like this happen so
what what does that say about me for
making this it says that you're it says
that you're a brilliant businessman not
just a great boxer and that's what I
always spoke about that's what I always
spoke about I give my credit about what
I do in the ring but I don't get my
credit about what I do on the outside
what did you get that that business says
because you you surpassed everybody in
in boxing and sports and everything in
general I'm watching you look like you
bigger than a NFL franchise it's just
what's he me believe it you know I'm
gonna be honest me and a lot of my guys
a lot of my said I have a team also but
you know my team don't get in there and
go to war like I go to war but they go
to war on the outside I can't go to war
I'm very very tough on my team I want my
team to be the best that they can be on
the outside and but as far as on the
outside you know al Heyman that's all
GOG a legend a legend a very shrewd
businessman learner ellaby that master
degree oh you know in business so you
know when you surround yourself with
people like this just just being around
certain individual certain individuals
like even been around Don King been
around Bob Arum been around just
different people that's been in the game
a long time and and you know my being
there buddies you know every time I got
around my being there buddies I was more
like it's cool to come over your house
but I need a house like this yeah it's
cool to ride on your yacht but I need to
got like this is cool around on your jet
but I want to get like patches and I
said no I don't
right on yours you showed me how to get
it you can't be my friend if you can't
show me how to get it because the ones
they showed me how to get it in I can
install it in my children then it goes
it goes it drives down some bloodline
yes so it's about wealth you know I'm no
longer rich and welcome another thing
about my career I never wanted you know
Forrest you know make it wait when you
asked me about
javante tank make him wait he's young
but when I was young I think I would
have made those same mistakes if I
didn't have my father in my life you
know just being a coach that was
extremely hard on me you know I think
that if he didn't discipline me in
boxing I don't really know where you
know how my career would have played out
you know I didn't want to slack and I
don't want to seem irresponsible or not
disciplined so that's why I always
Sakura you got to sacrifice something to
get some so that's why I've always made
sacrifices to get to a certain level and
to get to the pinnacle you got to make
sacrifices and that's what I did why is
the money so important why do you always
come back to the dollars people want to
know I mean you obviously have a
fascination you've earned a lot you show
it all the time you talk about a lot
what why is it always come to money um
why not I mean everything you got don't
cost money everything you do cost money
you can take your wife on a date for
free is that how you measure your
success no I mean I'm loyal and honest
and I'm a good person and I call the
spade a spade money don't make me I make
money and without money I'd be the same
person for so many fights for free
you're getting emotional no not at all
no I'm thank you you know I'm always
thinking how can I get better how can
our company grow how can I continue to
teach people around me how to fish and I
don't want to fish for would you try to
become entrepreneurs and if we can't we
want you to be the best that you can be
if you up under the banner
[Music]
good luck good luck to you too
a dance partner to dance with Conor
McGregor you a hell of a champion and to
the country of Ireland we love you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
big round of applause for two classy
classy gentlemen
[Applause]
[Music]
but I gave my heart our fair Plato he is
a composed man you cannot you can give
him nothing with respect it hooked the
shot early and he took shelter he
cracked him on the left hand and I saw
I'm in a bit of panic but he stayed very
very calm that's just as years of
expertise a tough competitor and he
still have a long career I had to him
does he have a career in boxing he's you
know we had to get his condition a
little bit better on that a little bit
explain what you liked about the boxing
business and what you prefer about the
MMA business this is all right it's not
bad
[Music]
Boyd congratulations terrific career
[Music]
and gentlemen you know to the podium I
like the color
the notorious one Conor McGregor
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up everybody he changed he's
composed compose hit me in hands hands
up towards your forehead dipped in head
forehead on the chest and sad to fight
that kind of fight I didn't anticipate
that tree tree game changed in the in
the fight that's what a true champion
does much respect you I mean I gotta
give respect to that was a hell of a
play
was he better than you had expected he's
a lot better than I thought he was he
used different angles
he was a tough competitor but I was the
better man tonight in there so he was
making me try when he was patient with
his shots I've got to get a number
respects fair play come great career
he's had
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Dreamchasers
motivation asked me to if there's
someone you like me to profile in their
future top ten please check out the link
down in the description below and you
can cast your vote on who we should do
next I also want to give a quick shout
out to Syrus Webb Cyrus thank you so
much for picking up a cup of my book
your one word and posting that awesome
picture to your audience on Twitter and
also the five star review you left on
Amazon I really really really appreciate
the support man and I'm so glad that you
enjoyed the book thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
can too need to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
Floyd just to follow up on Connor
there's a lot of concern coming into
this fight that the rules were gonna be
followed and it was a little bit rough
in times in there there was some there
was some warnings how did you feel about
the way Connor conducted himself in the
ring tonight
I let the referee do his job you know I
let the referee do his job
I let the referee to his job I'm not
here to bash the referee I mean but you
guys know what's going on a lot of rapid
punching a lot you know things happen
but you know you live and you learn
you know the referee the hell of a
referee kind of McGregor the hell of a
fighter I'm not here to bash anyone I
don't want out there to do my job
tonight as you've been away from the
game and you reflect on your life in
your career right now yes where are you
just looking at the life of Floyd
Mayweather just looking at my life I
don't think most people can handle I had
to be into my shoes yo-yo
you got I don't think it's for me that's
right now I don't think no one can
handle my situation why not hey you just
can't
what's the situation that can't be
handled I'm saying it's like I mean they
feel like it's pressure on me I mean
like I say they try to defeat me in many
different ways they try to bring up the
tax thing they try to bring up he's
being locked up I mean he's arrogant
he's I don't appreciate any years and
years and years they've been trying
their best to defeat me mentally I can't
be defeated I'm a strong individual
nothing can throw me off
nothing throwing me off told me off key
I'm always focused on what I got to do
and that's gonna be the case August 26th
I was 26 when we've really interested
like I said and I'm not backing up
remember I told you that you're not
backing up I'm not backing up a hospital
hustler I go for the jugular couldn't
work in a job I body cuts out the
customer I smuggled a smuggler I'm the
first one to cry I'm a bad boy I always
do I was shine
I bang with the bangus I flamed with the
flames you know what my name is
I'm a little famous than alias I hate
all the haters cut the lights off in
Vegas we making this money but this
money don't make us I'm taking my time
ain't got time for the taking I went ham
in the streets just to bring home the
bacon